i have 100 minecraft players trapped
here and we built the tallest mountain
in all of minecraft and rigged it with
super hard obstacle courses it's almost
as hard as me hi tall as me see this
freestore video we had obstacle courses
in that that was easy compared to what
we're doing today i'm an innocent player
just climbing the mountain boom
i'm hit with this we do this we get
through this but then we get over here
and you gotta go boom and you get the
point the further we go the harder it
gets but also the winner gets ten
thousand dollars you know how we do it
here let's start the challenge
oh let's go oh i'm on fire already and
here they go what would chris do in your
position carl well they'd give some uh
tips to people that can't hear us i feel
like he would try to screw you but since
you're with me you should continue the
torch and try to screw chandler
i killed boy jedi
the wood just broke in front of me oh
you can hit people oh you can hit people
now
ruining kids chances for money
back in the lava
they're battling on the stairs
oh wait shut up you're dying i just
burned to do that
i made it wait guys stop fighting this
is chaos oh carl stop being such a nice
guy you're the opposite of chris chris
would screw people and but you help him
yo open up the next gay i'm dying
they hit me what the heck i forgot
you're playing on chris's account i
couldn't tell because i'm scared to go
to third person now because everybody
attacked me for parkouring in third
person
i just
boy jedi do you want to get good at the
video game i don't know so is the is the
third gate not open what channel you
want me to open the gate
i died it's too late now they already
killed me well now that chandler's died
uh server please open up the next gate
thank you
oh this one's crazy here carl you keep
messing with people i want to see if i
can do this so you go from this block to
this block
to this block
this is easy
carl why are you laughing so hard i've
never gotten to ruin kids days like this
what are you the joker
what
is that how people feel when we just
randomly screw them over imagine if you
were competing for ten thousand dollars
and it happened you're right you're
right honestly just for that
i'm gonna do it still
no
wait are we competing for 10 grand i
keep dying look at boy jedi let's see oh
jedi
carl i blame you you're just bad at
minecraft i think wow who won a
challenge
attention everybody i forgot to tell you
but first one to finish gets 10 grand
look at this one coming up do you see
this this is impossible we took this map
to a different level by the way we've
built all our maps in-house in case you
didn't know i build them
before we open the next gate i want to
call dream because he didn't show up
ah
i can't i can't do this it's okay
chandler you can make it up here i made
it up you can join me sorry this is how
it works
you know i wonder if techno will pick up
techno would have picked up server over
and out open the gate while you guys do
this challenge i'm gonna go try to get a
hold of techno
oh come on keep going dude you got it oh
he made it i don't have enough practice
ruining people's day
what i shifted chris is just so good at
ruining people's day i don't i'm not
like used to it ruined my day twice now
this is the guy that almost won that 100
chunks map
we only support winners around here
doing a terrible job of supporting me
no
all right i'm really sad dream and
techno are ignoring me here if you want
to talk to somebody that's really good
at minecraft i actually know a guy
hi i'm carl i knew that was coming oh
this is why you have no facecam all
right open the next gate because carl's
jokes are predictable jertsu is
currently in the beginning carl i love
how they don't trust you lame blocks
look
that's what you get for trying to cheat
when i said this is the hardest
challenge we've ever done i've been
because carl is apparently way worse
than chris okay they thought they were
gonna get handouts their church already
won 10 grand he also won the award for
being the biggest nerd i hate parkour
what part of the course are you at jayla
yellow wool so you've been doing all the
obstacle course all the way over i saw
him flying
look at me even though it's weird
because you're on carl's account nope
chandler taylor i'm just being carl man
chandler would i ever cheat we have
morals and ethics you are banished from
this challenge what sorry no i'm gone
chad you can't do that you just made a
hole for everyone
let's go i'm banned they banned me all
right open the next skate apparently
chandler if you get us a burger from
mcdonald's we will unban you carl wants
to make chicken they baby from the
server i'm gonna go get mcdonald's for
the boys
where are my keys
server open the next gates carl this
one's actually pretty insane this is
scary it's funny because i wouldn't have
even made it this far to witness this
part we got a few people still doing the
yellow wool a few people on ice to death
got some people at the cobwebs of death
got some people here at the
bedrock of death so many people are
still at the first one wait but i just
found somebody that has a dream skin but
red should we get him to enter the chat
he's our new dream off-brand dream he's
dream but good
oh well gerkley all right well he's not
a dream master that's me millions of
people are watching right now what do
you want to say to them join the mr
peace official discord yeah yeah
oh i might have broke a hole through
let's see who finds it only the biggest
of the brain people will see that hole
the rest are over here they don't see it
they're so dumb i hate these ones yeah
they're so dumb for not predicting that
i was randomly gonna break a hole oh
also the gate drop for the not big brain
people i wonder what chandler's up to i
wonder if he's at mcdonald's yet oh yeah
he better be getting me my chicken i'm
here can i get a mcchicken three
mcdoubles and then an oreo mcflurry
medium and a small fry and a large
sprite are you guys gonna unban me now
this guy is currently on track to win
ten thousand dollars let's see who's in
second jertsu
you freaking slowpoke yo boy jedi
sprinting boy jedi you still here yeah
i'm still here you're currently at third
place
boy jedi you're currently in last place
cmr yo how's it going bro hey what's up
man currently you are in first place oh
that's pretty cool if you win the 10
grand what are you gonna buy uh
probably a lampshade hey jertsu yeah you
already won 10 grand what did you spend
it on i haven't spent it at all yet but
i think i'm gonna buy a holiday for me
we just had the fourth of july so you
can't buy that one
[Music]
we got about 10 people here the other 90
people are still catching up but we're
not gonna wait on them this next course
is this lava pit right here and then
they come up these stairs and up these
stairs is the walkway of death but if
they make it across that 10 grand awaits
these 10 are about to compete for 10 000
but if they fall they go all the way
back to the beginning yeah there's no
coming back dear server alpha delta 49er
roger that means uh open the gate
there we go oh someone fell
oh someone else fell they're falling
already oh oh oh wait these blocks do
damage i forgot they don't have time
they gotta go
see a rim is he out yeah well he fell so
he's at the beginning now
mip the turtle vip
map
oh my gosh it's a race to the finish oh
my gosh they're blitzing they're
blitzing it's literally any man's game
they don't know this but there's not
another barrier it's just a straight
shot oh my gosh these three are walking
up the stairs to heaven and they don't
even realize it dude it's so close all
right will he make it will he make it oh
you don't have time to stop touching oh
oh my gosh he needs to be a little bit
more slow and steady
all right second place fell turtle it is
all him he can take his time i don't
even think he realizes they fell he
thinks they're still oh
what a hatchet
it was right there there was like five
pieces of ice between him and ten
thousand dollars amit doesn't realize it
but he's in first place and he's a
previous winner
oh wait too late yo techno techno just
uh replied to my dm 30 seconds ago let's
get techno in here and see if he can win
there's nobody even in the previous
obstacle where is everybody dad hey you
guys wanted it harder we made it harder
smk
hello you are currently in the lead by a
lot
you were in the lead by a lot
i'm sorry
man i'm so freaking sorry where is
chandler at is he back with the
mcdonald's yeah
wait hold up is this yo is this techno
hello
we're doing a minecraft parkour
challenge with 100 people and they
cannot complete it could you join and
try to beat everyone oh sure okay here
i'm gonna send you a discord link techno
wait cameron's at the finish line he's
about to do it wait so cameron almost
won died came all the way back up and is
about to win again dude there's 90 other
players what are they doing all right
cameron see that chair over there you
sit in that chair you get 10 grand you
might want to hurry there's people
running up behind you oh cameron there's
tons of people catching up that is fine
this is this is easy peasy what can i
say all right so
where's my uh ten thousand
lampshade i'm actually going to what am
i going to do with it
oh my gosh oh
i think i'm going to
love
it
i'm slightly overwhelmed he ran to his
mom immediately oh mr beast my mom is
here can we talk to your mom hi
hello so your son just won ten thousand
dollars your son's better than
technoblade it says you're better than
technical yeah then take no blade
cameron what are you going to spend the
10 grand on bye um on your computer
enjoy your new computer thank you so
much for coming out subscribe everybody
and we'll see you in the next video
guys look at look what i got
what
they finished
they finished filming